at last came in 2013 red barrel games
open montreal quebec canada it's at the
ready yeah yeah quebec quebec kid big
monorail all that poutine land and that
was a really popular game came out a
bunch of consoles and pc he streamed a
lot as well I feel like it was a big
like streaming success at first one at
last to you got to play it at pax yeah
tell me about a Michael my Hardy so it
as of now does not seem connected to LS
1 there might be some like threads
actually tying them together a little
bit but seems like its own thing so it's
not it's not taking place in a the first
one was in like a mental institution
Angeles use this one kind of jumps back
and forth between a bunch of places it
seemed like it was just the beginning of
the game although that could just be the
demo purposes but it starts off it's
very much like the conjuring if you've
seen it based on that supposedly real
couple who is always like in paranormal
investigators if we connect names what's
not the move if you've seen the
conjuring it's like it's based on these
people who wrote a book it's supposedly
real I don't know and you're these two
investigative journalists that go
somewhere into the American Southwest
and there's this big darkness that's
just covered the Lance you go to
investigate it and of course things go
wrong there's a car crash and then
you're separated from your the you're
the guy so you're separated from your
wife and you're going through this kind
of abandoned resident evil forest town
at the beginning okay there's a Spanish
people yeah ganado sand everything yeah
slowly walking I'm glad and then the
president keeps calling you that doesn't
have it reasonable for um you're
essentially you're going through yeah
that abandoned town and it's very it's
all decaying dilapidated but then you
know that's well anything it jumps to
this like schoolhouse all of a sudden
through like it's weird supernatural
part and it becomes kind of like the
poltergeist where there's just this
invisible thing slamming lockers and you
go hide in one and every time you go
into the cafeteria you see these people
quick flashes outside of the windows so
it's like genre jumping con yeah it
doesn't really well to from the 15
minutes we played mary and i played it
and and then it goes to this thing at
the end there's like it's just like the
axe murderer that kind of chases you
down and it's really good in very much
like the first game and not
speaking about jumpscares which can be
cheap mmm the jump-scares in this game
so far it felt like it earned them the
first game was pretty creepy as well
though so get a good like feeling of
dress yeah mented yeah yeah I do not
like being in this place yes yeah I was
a good blend of gore just like that
disturbing kind of horror like
unsettling I think and it jumped really
well between those and then also that it
has that look over the shoulder function
that kind of really messes with you
because you know like it's like
Guillermo del Toro he always shows the
monster contrary what a lot of other
filmmakers don't and that's kind of like
what they're doing and you know you look
of your shoulder while you're being
chased by a bunch of these angry
villagers or almost like this this
undead family and you're going through
this cornfield at the end and I saw Mary
went off the path like into the corn
which seems logical but then she hidden
this barrel and you could see like the
holes in it and then all of a sudden
like a bunch of these people are passing
by and I was looking one just stops and
turns toward her nose she got killed I
died at one part to a different part but
I just took the path and the butt of
looking over your shoulder at the people
chasing you terrifying it's it's so much
like more dreadful than jump scares ya
in such a great way because it's just
this dread that really pushes throughout
the whole there are several games that
do that chasing sequence in horror games
good the remember um Call of Cthulhu
dark corners of the earth yeah the xbox
yeah it was on PC as well i think i
think it was what I played it on yeah
that was in the game where you were like
running away from the townspeople and
like running into doors like pushing
things against the door so it would take
them longer to like break in and stuff
and those sequences were effective how
long were they the chase itself there
was one chase in this game unless you
count the school because you kind of
feel like you're being chased even
though I don't think technically you
were right it lasted about 20 seconds
you're skating this house into the
cornfield through this little farm and
you're hearing these people just
shouting some weird like guttural
language I don't know what it was
supposed to be it definitely was not
what people in the American Southwest
speaking yeah yeah was it quite open i
remember the first game maybe i'm
thinking wrong maybe i didn't play an
awful i remember being quite like tice
corridor kind of crawly like it opened
up some airways but like it was never
like open it was more i was more like
resident evil or metroid almost you kind
of go into certain areas the doors are
locked then you figure out
go to the basement and then backtrack a
little bit this was far more linear than
the first gave me the first game wasn't
open but it was still kind of you could
explore looks might be the purpose of a
demo those well exactly yeah so I don't
know how much of this will translate
into the the game itself did the map was
just looking through like going through
coral sure that seems like it like
doesn't yes space definitely yeah one
hundred percent the environments
themselves are very much more you can go
down multiple paths or just completely
ignore the path like mary did and just
go off into the cornfield it it it was
good joining the way it jumped between
environments but also in just how like
these different types of horror there's
one part where it almost approached that
kind of japanese style like the grudge
or the ring with the girl with my hair
over her face and optical pretty
terrifying to ya like it it was a very
scary demo yeah how long were you in
there for 15 minutes it was also cool
the booth itself at the show you kind of
see it from afar it's like this mini
black chapel and then when he walked in
some sections of it yeah the three
booths you're playing and have curtains
over them and it's like confessional
boots and all the guys himself said like
are you ready to confess oh my god i
don't i don't think so but the cheesy
but effective what about the camera
stuff is any i mean changes the dash the
sort of hearing the light vision and why
not i quite like that the start how it
was the one thing I always wanted him to
do in like half life 3 was like give
Gordon's glasses presents where you
knock them off and when you put them on
you see clearly the glass ever come off
as well does the camera stuff ever got
play yeah it was just your kind of
scavenging for batteries not not to
constantly that it takes away from the
experience itself but enough that kind
of lens this good tension to it because
you're finding batteries in these
abandoned homes to you know recharge
your camera use an isolation [ __ ] if
I'm looking for batteries my xbox one
controller it's always takes me like 20
minutes you oh yeah abandoned cornfield
houses of just double a's lying around
yeah they don't have like officemax or
anything so i imagine like the bob
enough they like load up on them you
think I guess I like buying bulk yeah
well there's parts where you cannot see
anything because the whole idea is that
you're investigating what this darkness
is and there's parts where it's pitch
black and you're screwed and there's you
know you're getting chased by things at
certain points and your kind of managing
your night vision which is cool touch
the first game did it but this one did
it really well
that you can't see at certain parts so
you really have to just rely on the bat
manage the battery life or just rely on
instinct when you're trying to find your
way through the hallways battery
management it's like being at pax being
a camera placed in the packs Luna 9 also
saying our last one of the games and
Steam library I've yet to play I feel
like it's one of those games that
everyone kind of has but maybe a lot of
people if I haven't completed it was it
on PSN PA playstation plus I feel like
or something the last made it to
PlayStation I created some it's on ps4
guys actually in really I played it i
never played it on steam i had heard
about it but like i was in your
situation I never got around to it and
then yeah played it on it was one of the
earlier games I played on ps4 um yeah I
played it right after like Lego Marvel
Super Heroes I think was right when all
that twitch study I was a good contrast
yeah it was moldy ghost Lego Marvel and
then outlast a pretty positive good
Saturday night I like it thank you so
much for telling us all about it when is
it coming out how are you feeling about
it actually in terms of like did you
want to play more I did it feel like a
new take on the sort of tried and tested
formula because i feel like if any genre
goes down the line of will just copy the
same thing over and over again it's not
horror genre it felt very good like the
first game did I didn't think the first
game was spectacular but it was
definitely I I thought it's great this
one seems like it's taking that base
those base mechanics and just putting in
these environments I want to explore but
also don't because it was pretty scary
sweet i'm excited for you yeah thank you
Michael my hearty and fall ball coming
out in the fall halloween course it is
yeah why would you ever release the game
they're aiming for is what they told me
they mean they sounded tentative but
we'll find out all right yeah Cheers